for the rangers this evening it'll be
the left-hander colby allard going
tonight it'll be his 12th start of the
season
and this one off the handle hangs up in
the arrow moment out in center field a
diving catch
by adolesce garcia i wasn't so sure he'd
get to it but
he always has just enough and he makes
the play
[Applause]
and he strikes out ohtani looking beauty
right on the outside corner two away
we just told you about the command of
colby allard how good it has been
this season and he paints a fourth scene
fastball right on the corner
and when you see that little first
movement from ohtani you talk about how
he opens up a little bit you can throw
pitches like this with consistency he
would have a hard time getting to them
shohei ohtani goes to work on the mount
for the halos making his 16th start of
the year on the mound tonight
and this ball hit sharply past third and
down into that left field corner
nathaniel around first and he will
cruise into second base with a one-out
double and there goes nate lowe once
again to the opposite field something
he's done so well
pitch to heim on its way runner at third
with two gone
and heim sends that out to right adele's
under it to retire the side
without incident
and lagares has a ball back up the
middle for a base hit
yeah aggressive on the first pitch
hitters this year 343 on the first pitch
against allard
and mayfield has a base hit to right he
keeps doing that he's going to play a
lot i was just going to say that as
we keep getting hits going that way we
know the power and we've seen some home
runs
with five this year but hitting the ball
hard the other way every bit is
important to see that
this will be the seventh pitch of this
pack and he swings and misses strike
three
so rather punches him out just the
second
strikeout with the runners at first and
second and see if shohei can help his
own cause here there's a pitch and
that's low and that one skips away from
the catcher heim he can't find it and
now breaking for the plate and the throw
is late and
coming in and scoring the first run in
the ball game for the angels is lagarres
he comes in all the way from second base
on a
wild pitch and the angels lead it one to
nothing
3-1 and this one's smashed down to first
low's right there he'll go to the bag
himself
and the inning is done mayfield left at
third but
the angels get that first run of the
night
the next two strike pitch and with this
one he strikes out brock holt his first
punch out of the night
andy that one what an adjustment on that
one he stayed on top whatever you don't
stand on top of the baseball means you
have your fingers split open for the
splitter but you stay on top
with the rotation of the baseball hands
on top
under the baseball and it drops straight
down quick adjustment nice play by kurt
suzuki on the foul tip
pick up the first punch up
and he gets terry looking now he's got a
feel for his slider working that quick
adjustment on the splitter
and now a slider working a ball in two
strikes to low
three strikeouts for shohei ohtani
runner left stranded still one nothing
angel
o2 pitch from allard and that one good
right in there strike three called
third strikeout tonight for colby
one-two pitch whoa comebacker and a
great stop back of second base
by amanez makes another nifty play i
don't know
how allard managed to navigate the
matrix there to
miss that one
little nubber back to ohtani who makes
easy work of it for the first out of the
inning
and that is 16 straight lead off men
retired by shohei ohtani it's the
longest active streak in baseball
andy aponyas on the first pitch sends a
fly ball out to left for justin upton
and it's a one two
three fourth for shohei ohtani still one
nothing halo
still one nothing angels here in the
fifth and jack mayfield who's had a hit
his only time up in this game will be
the next batter
mayfield sends a ball well hit out to
left center field and captain jack has
hit it high again
you cannot contain captain jack
oh captain no captain you did it again
sixth home run and here's the next pitch
that's a shot down the left field side
that ball's well hit down in the left
field corner and boy it bangs off the
top of the wall
fletcher is headed for second he'll make
a turn he's headed for third and he'll
slide in with a triple
boy he almost hit one out that came very
close to leaving and
fletcher gets his second triple of the
season
and he hits his ball a ton but straight
up in the air out to right
peters read it perfectly waits on it
and that will do it in the fifth inning
but the angels do add a run on the
mayfield home
got him four for rotani tonight
that the reason why he got away that was
a slider almost right down the heart of
the plate reason why
the pitch before was 98 miles an hour
two balls and two strikes to curtis
terry trying to strand the base runner
and terry is rung up
he has five in five innings he strikes
out looking for the second time in the
ball game and that is how the inning
will end
0-2 that one flared out to right field
peter's coming on he makes
the catch nicely done as he goes into a
little slide
upton retired one away it's a really
nice play this is kind of an
in-betweener
for dj peters who wasn't sure if he was
going to lay out slide or let it bounce
in front of him
and gets it done either way
to find starters ground ball short stop
to second one
about his defers in time got him
six four three double play and it ends
the inning
and he hits this ball hard not into left
field that will be extra bases
around out of that left field corner and
isaiah with a lead off double
in the sixth with the two-run angels
lead garcia is over two
and a chopper shortstop that'll get a
run home iglesias
goes to first but garcia drives in the
first rangers run of the ball game it's
a 2-1
game on the rbi groundout ohtani's ready
the counts one ball two strikes here's
the next pitch
and there's a swing and a miss he got
him with the splitter
struck him out and that is the end of
the inning
shohei's sixth strikeout tonight he
hasn't walked a single batter and
the rangers do get a run though and it's
2-1 angels
stuff to stay in there again you're
trying to protect against that slider
away so it makes it hard to pick up the
fastball in
this one it just fights it off in the
right field that's a base hit so isaiah
with his third hit of the night
[Music]
it is a strikeout and the throw down to
second
ask and you shall receive partner strike
him out
throw him out halos out of the kitchen
in the eighth
if the angels win they'll get back to
500 for the
20th time this season
there's your ground ball mayfield to
fletcher
back to goslin and that'll do it a 23rd
save
by reichsel iglesias how much has he
meant to this club
i love the fact that the angels kept him
sent a message into the clubhouse
they were still about winning games you
have a chance to win when you have
iglesias on the bump to close it out